this is apparently the weekend for Jonah
Hill to bein sequels that are better
than the original How to Train Your
Dragon 2 is the sequel to the oddly
titled original film that was a
humongous surprise both from critics
fans and the box office because
originally people were like that movie
has a strange title the trailers aren't
that good
Sony DreamWorks hasn't really made a
great movie in a while what are they
gonna be doing with this movie it's
gonna lose a lot of money and it was
actually a very good movie did really
well the box office now there's a
television show and a new film in this
film hiccup is dealing with a bit of a
personal dilemma his dad wants him to be
the new chief over his village he's got
a new girlfriend and some things from
his past are starting to come back and
haunt him there's also a war brewing
amongst these people that want to
capture dragons and all this stuff comes
to a head in a film that outshines the
original this film goes places the
original didn't go in regards to
character it's really a very adult
animated film at its core the story
elements to it are very much so in the
vein of something that entire family
could enjoy where kids can get involved
with the cool flying dragon scenes and
enjoy that the 3d looks very cool adults
can actually get into the story and be
invested in it because it is actually a
very mature film and that was one of the
things that I loved about this movie it
was so refreshing to see an animated
film that is aimed largely at families
and children treat those children with
respect this film actually expects
children to sit there and be invested in
the story and I'll just be like oh
that's so cool all dragons yay and that
is something that a large majority of
the entertainment that's out there for
kids today ignores there is a lot of
stuff going on under the surface in
regards to the way the film handles
family backgrounds and growing up and
maturing and the action-adventure
element of it too is a little bit more
dark than the first one was and that's
one of the reasons why I think as a
family film this is a very special movie
beyond the fact the music is terrific
the CGI is beautiful and breathtaking
and all the technical aspects of the
film like the character animations and
how human they were having perfect the
characters look that made them look more
human those things boost the technical
credits of this movie but the actual
story behind it is also very well done
also it's just great to see tooth
being cute and awesome as a dragon it
has the fun aspects of it too it's a
film that you can sit and watch and
enjoy but also really get into the
action scenes it's a surprisingly
touching and moving movie I know it's a
dragon movie for families but it's it's
good the main villain in the film at
first was like just an evil guy you just
kind of heard about him a lot you didn't
seem too much you didn't know much about
him if anything really he just heard
like one tiny little backstory and so at
first the villain was kind of weak I
thought but as the film progressed and
his evilness began to pour out of him I
was like this guy is he's a butthole
that was kind of one of the weaker
elements of the film was the villain
didn't really feel like he had much of a
presence at first but as the film
continued to go on and his evil deeds
became more and more evil I was like
this is actually a pretty cool villain
for a kid's film he does have the
cliched eye scar though like does every
villain in one of these movies have to
have an eye scar it's like it sets up
this backstory like wow that guy is
seriously hardcore
he got cut across the eye one time and
he's evil and that he doesn't like
people because he got cut on guy how to
train your dragon to is a surprisingly
emotional experience the villain is a
little weak at first but he improves as
the film goes on the action scenes are
handled very well in the technical
credits of this movie are astoundingly
good
there was even aspects of it they
reminded me a little bit of Hayao
Miyazaki's princess mononoke when he
finds like this
unknown world that's hidden around this
ice it really reminded me of the forest
spirit scenes and Princess Mononoke
I would say this and the lego movie are
the two animated films we've had so far
this year that I think are the best and
I like this one even more than a lego
movie I'm gonna give how to train your
dragon to a a - I think it is an
excellent kids film one that they can
actually enjoy that doesn't pander to
them that actually respects them as an
audience member
cuz if you've seen this film let me know
what you thought of it below and if
you've seen the original let me know
what you thought how do they compare in
your book thanks as always for watching
guys and if you liked this you can click
right here and get steppen eyes
I also want to let you guys know really
quick that my promotion with
shutterstock.com is still running this
is a very cool website for independent
filmmakers like myself and like many of
you who have contacted me and told me
that you are looking for ways to improve
your short films sometimes you just
can't get that one shot you need trust
me I know I've been there shudders calm
contacted me and wanted to do a
promotion with me basically there are
website that allows you to use very high
quality footage legally like over city
shots and awesome big things like that
that we just can't get until we got that
budget that we wish we had but if you go
to shutterstock.com and use the promo
code kris six one four you can get 20%
off your membership and that's a gift
from me through shutters comm so please
check them out sometimes
shutterstock.com promo code kris six one
four thanks guys you rock